[Music]
so yesterday on our patreon show
patreon.com we're not sorry we covered
the original uh video because he
confronted dan crenshaw twice
um and the first one you know everybody
saw it he said eyepatch mccain iraq war
whatever it looks like they're about to
activate their wonder twins powers they
are and um
here's what happened
dan you're just such a little loser
who's trying to grab my thing
look you're too slow
if he had done that to dan
he would be he would be a real prisoner
he would be in federal prison right now
he'd be getting cornholed in the pen
right but he could do whatever he wants
well yes
dan you're just such a little loser you
know any of this right now
who's trying to grab my thing
look you're too slow
he's too slow navy seal it's funny dan
hey you said you're tall you i'm small
but i'm so much taller than you dan
by this guy's kind of laughing a little
bit can we point that out i mean i don't
know who this guy is but can we just
point out that this this guy's kind of
like
this guy's a face of like yeah we make
fun of his height too when he's not
around like just whatever
i'm so much bigger than you oh you
understand alex is phoned on account of
you know the lack of depth perception is
that brave muhammed warrior
but it's it's funny because
this is why a lot of people
i think
sometimes a lot of some people write off
alex stein because oh he's just some
troll he's just screaming
there's an art to this and i know people
don't understand that some people don't
but there's an art to this the
he knows how to needle people different
he's noticing notice something he's not
needling dan crenshaw the way he needed
aoc or the name he needled uh [ __ ]
spy [ __ ] um
he knows dan crenshaw's a military guy
he knows he's just a temper because he's
seen him yell at 12 year olds so he
knows the best way to go you're such a
big guy he's the weak link in the chain
exactly
was like
okay yeah just kept what like ignored
him yeah you're right he's like because
he's giving him something because he's
already like you said he yelled at the
little girl crenshaw already has a very
and i said this last night on nightweave
because i played this video crenshaw has
a bad temper yeah and the other thing
that's great about him is he's very bad
at
thinking on his feet or improving right
or having an organic conversation i mean
if you can think on his feet he'd have
two eyes
sorry go ahead i apologize i'm not look
it's right i get that that's mean right
damn it that was good but is it wrong
that was it could be both i think um
it could be wrong and funny that he
couldn't see oh the thing okay i think
you're in eyes sorry apologies
but yeah no he's uh he's definitely the
weak link in the chain and i like that
alex is like if i poke at this guy
enough he's gonna he's gonna give me a
reaction and of course
you're just a little you're a little sad
little boy
the little one could you imagine this is
like yeah imagine me calling you out
because you're a nile and you're a
globalist
oh i got a job i work for the play
begging for twitter likes
this by the way what you're seeing here
and this is why i love this it's not so
much about pissing off dan crenshaw
it's it's about showing you it's it's
about showing you
who these people think they are
you know what i mean oh imagine being
one of them going for likes and
interactions and
it's it's this level of superiority that
all of these [ __ ] have
i also like this this young
uprising this like republican civil war
that's going on now with the young go
hearts
and i love the fact that like
you'll see leftists on twitter like uh
yeah right-wing tears i'm gonna be
drinking right wing tears all week cause
i but all these right-wingers are pissed
that their their shit's collapsing and
i'm like no most of the right-wingers
are very excited about this this is
awesome
some of us are very excited about this
this [ __ ] rules
seeing them fall apart like this
is objectively hilarious because here's
the thing
the difference between everything is is
that
i would rather have nothing
that have so for whatever reason
yesterday
um
i had retweeted you know alex stein
sings or whatever you know sometimes you
get caught up in a wee like you get
caught up in something that a
conversation that you're not a part of
in a tweet you're like okay [ __ ]
christ i just i said one thing i don't
know
now the rest of the evening but whatever
it was on the comment on one of alex's
things but when i bring it up is like
the person that's tr the woman the
democrat that's trying to primary that's
trying to primary that's trying to beat
crenshaw here coming up in the election
tweeted some someone wrote like man i
just really hate crenshaw and she tried
to like get in on the uh
getting all the attention and she
commented her a little verified account
she was like you could vote for me i
won't tell anybody and it was a midi
like [ __ ] beat it we don't want you
here let out of here you loser
go [ __ ] yourself i'd rather have none of
you get out of here
i got i make a lot of money yeah i do
yeah i do dude yeah i make a surprising
amount a lot of money
yeah i'm a loser
this is the guy this is the guy who
tells veterans that they're about their
services
yeah yes your service was wasted for
israel i don't care
i am none
9 11 was a long time ago you hate our
troops yes
9 11 i don't care anymore 9 11 was a
long time ago yeah i don't want our
troops to go die for [ __ ] but i'm
the [ __ ] but i i hate our troops i
don't want them to die but i'm the bad
guy go [ __ ] yourself i'm the bad guy i'm
the one that doesn't have an eye patch
yeah good point you literally
have an ipad goatee he needs a goatee
goatee he needs to go ti patch look
because these are weapons of mass
destruction that didn't exist
i'm an anti-war yeah
yes yes yes you know what
sometimes and you know what really sucks
with these people they don't get it
sometimes
your service is a waste okay and it's
not your fault either it's not even the
troops fault that their service was a
waste but the problem isn't the whole
point is we need to hold people
accountable that wastes
lives
also the wounded worry come on man she
being annoying yes
the wounded warrior project
does anyone have any stats
on on like
how much they actually do like i know
they do some stuff oh oh i can grab
those but thank you but it is a giant
organization right and i'm thinking
probably a lot of
a lot of salaries get paid it's a lot of
bloated sort of like you know i'm sure
their their [ __ ] budget is bloated so
like
it's kind of a grift like and crenshaw
walks around with just wounded warrior
guys all the time all the time dude it's
a literal human shield
walking around with a human shield i
walk around with three guys from the
wounded warrior project two of the guys
from black rifle coffee and [ __ ]
and for some reason and for some reason
anomaly
wait why is he there i don't know
because he's rapping
or something i'll be honest with you man
i i've been i've been anomalies at least
lately on twitter has pretty [ __ ]
good
um let's see here a wounded warrior
project uh contributions ranks uh 10 702
out of 27 000 whatever
uh what is who is this uh top recipients
what am i looking at here
when a warrior project lobbying
100 elected open secrets no
here we go read this for me um
yeah they just take like political
action groups and political
organizations and or politicians and
just basically show you the donation
money it's real fun it's one of my
favorite websites to bring up when
people start talking about the nra and
you can show them that the nra donates
about one tenth of the [ __ ] teachers
union
oh yeah of course
so basically what this is showing is
that the top recipients of the wounded
warriors i see are democrats yeah yes
yes they are i okay i'm getting it now
sorry i've never okay i see what they're
doing here really oh my god i didn't
even mean to stumble on
so top recipients currently
are ben diamond
ben diamond come on
candidate come on man democrat for
florida the 13th district erwin stephen
sorry stephen irwin uh who is a
candidate for democrat in pennsylvania
and then he was dead and then the
different one and then a democratic uh
senatorial campaign committee so like a
group um to democratic so yeah so to
that
uh individual never failed i i was just
irony of dan crenshaw running to a group
of democrat supporters to defend him
from alex stein wow this is really good
great find virginia this is actually
really good great fine
i was just kind of
asking a question
great find
i had a hunch it was a always a grift
yeah a hundred percent it breaks it down
to party a hundred percent democrats and
a hundred percent percent to
non-incumbent so they're trying to beat
republicans they're not even trying to
re-elect let's say they google we're
trying a democrat who's been friendly to
us they're trying to beat republicans
holy [ __ ] this is hilarious
never fails
all right good fine
see that's why we keep you around
did you i was talking to marshall you
guys find any weapons
and by the way marsh i'll have you know
that if you try to come after me i
donate to the wounded warrior project
okay so you can't you cannot attack our
troops thank you and ben diamond
and stephen irwin benjamin diamond and
stephen irwin yes david cohen steinberg
wits
i mean jesus christ man
i had a hunch but [ __ ]
oh where was i good
you're actually going to go down this
route alex yeah
like a fool right now you're telling me
more money
uh hey uh alex stein's not a 12 year old
girl why are you so shook war hero
why are you so shook war hero you could
take an ied to the face but you can't
take a couple [ __ ] barbs come on man
get the [ __ ] out of here
who cares more about ukraine [ __ ]
john rambo
john ramble over here you're spitting on
vietnam veterans all of a sudden this
guy turns into john rambo i was how is
not wanting people to die
spitting on them or even a controversial
opinion to have
like the fact that we're to the point
now where you go hey man i would like
less people to die for dumb [ __ ] and the
fact that now you can't say that go [ __ ]
yourself dan how about that
i have a question
yeah
is dan crenshaw
a vietnam veteran no
but dan chris what the [ __ ] is he
talking about because i'm pretty sure
he's standing there talking about
explaining why cranshaw dan crenshaw is
the people that are surrounding him
however are vietnam veterans because
that's okay that's why cool but he's
insulting dan crenshaw
is this like
is this your show turning into like a
[ __ ] three-bedroom house with five
people living in and versus wandering in
stoned in the middle of [ __ ] like
cranshaw like um
is the
he's the guy
with the eye patch yes you're like
yeah man
you don't care that's your problem dan
you don't care about america you know
just cheer me out and i don't know if
you brought this up last night
if you're dan crenshaw
right i know what question you're going
to ask is the same thing i was just
about full are you okay so are we all on
the same page are we about to say the
same thing is it about the sunglasses
okay
why not wear a monocle sunglasses that
was brought up many times last night i'm
glad i'm not the only one i'm sorry it's
just
or lose the eye patch
because now you got you know he both he
has too many facial accessories right
too much it feels too much too much
because if you have the glasses on
there's no need for the eye patch right
imagine if he was wearing a hat oh no
imagine how silly that would be black
rifle coffee huh
you got a lot of cranial accessories oh
rip bro
do you think they're here
you should just you just poke out the
other eye oh two patches by the way this
is it right here this is a perfect
example of crenshaw not being able to
insult or think of something on his feet
listen to what he says here okay so i'm
back he's i used to be a comedian here
that's your problem dan you don't care
about america you don't care about texas
do you think there's a community is
there an invasion on
no i'm pausing perfectly because i know
i'm just building okay i'm ready i'm
ready i'm ready
here we go
is there an invasion on our border maybe
you should go back i still have a
community is there an invasion
i'm sorry pause
so he said can i break this down yeah
please i'm [ __ ] so hard cringing go
ahead
so
he said hey didn't you succumb he used
to be a comedian
maybe you should go back to the thing
that you're not good at
but
did that make any sense okay that's so
bad can i tag on to it you know you're
not so good at that you're not going
back to doing the thing you're not good
at that's what's gonna say you're you're
not you're not real good at that
bud keep practicing i guess by the way
it's funny keep something in mind all
these little talking points all these
little you know that he was the host on
what was it was it cheater was it
cheaters or blind dates
cheaters and all that kind of stuff all
that stuff is exactly dan crenshaw gets
all this [ __ ] from democrat [ __ ]
talking points that's what he does and
as everyone's pointing out in the chat
zelinski used to be a comedian too and
we're giving him 80 billion dollars
so you know oh you're right maybe maybe
no are you attacking the brave
ukrainians now dan yeah not even
russia's doing that so whatever um
there's an invasion on our border
why do you give 80 billion to ukraine
why do you give 80 billion to ukraine i
think again the numbers wrong there
buddy oh what 84 billion actually if you
count the if you count the current
number uh he what he's what he's doing
is he's playing that little semantics
thing where he goes uh i voted for 40.
but 40 before that as well though so
that 40 plus 40 is what 80. oh 80. plus
the weapons remember the weapons are
separate
by the way we gave them weapons that
were worth money too and he's leaving
those out we're not selling it to them
we are
giving it to them
we had a hundred billion now no it's not
even quite they're the ones selling it
after they get it by the way by the way
can i point something out now because i
just caught this there's so much this is
a short video and it's filled so much
stuff
i just cut this
it's not even close to that much
implying that even if he's wrong he's
not but even if he's wrong
40 billion still isn't a lot of our
money remember the wall was supposed to
be four just to keep that number in mind
that though
there was no way we could have came up
with four billion dollars for that wall
trump was insane why did the printer
break
during for four years at that time
which was actually a good thing yeah
it's the only good thing is one of the
good things that happened during the
trump administration we're out of money
we have two now dan and they even say
none of those weapons even go to they're
like look uh we need to we need to print
some more money mr president he's like
check the couch cushions
so why don't you start caring about
america
you don't care about america at all dan
you're a globalist you're
he knows now that he's getting very
close to the area where he can't be
followed that's why he's
he's getting more
he's recognized yeah now he's getting a
little more [ __ ] traitor you're a
dwarf there's dankers come on
come on modern day version of the people
oh i'm a piece of [ __ ] you're the one
that's a globalist you're killing young
children for no reason sending him to
war for nothing
and now this is the him talking to one
of the police yes
yeah i just need to politely harass you
to let you know passively aggressively
that you're not allowed to talk to that
alumni
has has anybody has said
yep that's for tomorrow has anybody ever
said
oh thank god a female cops here
everything's
fine has anybody ever been like oh good
a woman's here she's like sir uh you
know you have no it's like the old
patrice bit
like
if you're gonna arrest me right i want
you to be somebody that
could probably
physically subdue me even without a
badge and a gun
like there has to be a respect level
there he's like and like with little
tiny women cops especially remember
patrice was huge i think his line was
i'm i was i was i was i'm a six seven
black guy that used to play college
football you're only a cop because i
allow you to be that's right that's what
it was you're only a cop because i allow
you right it's
like yeah when you're wanting to
interview members
so
what's the problem here okay you cannot
physically stop them from going he
didn't physically stop them there's no
there was never any ever impeachment if
anything the
the representative snatched at his phone
which could be
constituted as battery
i'm not trying to talk back i didn't
physically stop anybody i'm just letting
you know from what we were getting from
members of the public was that you were
correct who
passing members that we're trying to huh
the [ __ ] the vietnam war vets or as i
call them losers
those guys
say i only like vets that win worse yeah
yeah i like guys you didn't get
[ __ ] madman i know i know bro go back
and forth to their votes you were not
allowed to do that
uh excuse me there's a big vote on
funding israel today so everyone's here
is alex stein going to end up on the
audit the audit channel
in this case we give alex stein a b plus
audit the other auditors yeah that's
there is a whole channel where he does
that where a guy actually watches their
videos and gives them report cards oh
yeah i've seen that see i've seen that
yeah for this the capital police get a c
minus
you know
the rules and the laws that you are
being told that you are breaking and i'm
going to let you know that that's what
you cannot do okay am i allowed to leave
you are allowed to leave okay thank you
thank you this is just trying to ask
politicians some questions and then they
come and detain me
what a joke because you weren't asking
questions that would make them feel
comfortable alex i'm sorry are you under
the impression that we still have a
first amendment
ah alex man only thing i tell you bro
and i and i say that i told him directly
i'm like you're doing
the lord's work what you're doing
needed to be done and anybody that's
coming after any of these [ __ ] neocon
that again did you see them all come out
of the woodwork yesterday by the way all
the little [ __ ] neocons attacks as
many as no no i know not as many as they
used to be
like there's that show based politics
it's these two [ __ ] neocons but you
know i'm talking about the show called
base politics yeah there's gonna be a
few but man i what i saw from crenshaw's
twitter
was him getting ratio to because he took
the video put it up on his own thing and
was like oh he's attacking veterans and
blah blah blah and he got
demolished on twitter on his own twitter
danny satan posted a screenshot and show
link he got okay [ __ ]
he got [ __ ]
battered on twitter all night last night
he thought he was gonna [ __ ] dunk on
alex stein
he deleted this
this tweet's deleted you said is that
correct am i
pretty sure yes
look at the ratio yeah okay
uh well america got [ __ ]
demolished wow that ratio is not
and by the way a lot of those retweets
those are quote tweets they're probably
like people being like [ __ ] you zio
klops yeah you piece of [ __ ] yeah so
yeah he got
battered last night we were just sitting
there bro at night we were just sitting
there just reading
just reading it in real time new
comments popping up every [ __ ] couple
minutes it was brutal
dan crenshaw
raised 13 million dollars
spent 12 million dollars
cash on hand 2.7 million dollars
uh top contributors of dan crenshaw
huntsman corp
american israeli public affairs
committee is number two
are you looking at his open secrets yes
everything yeah
open secrets is [ __ ] hilarious it is
amazing
i i can't believe you guys black rifle
coffee is his 20 uh top 20 contributing
black rifle coffee is number 20.
yeah of course
[Music]
go ahead keep defending black rifle
coffee they're really good dudes huh